as most of you guys know Dave Ramsey and
I don't exactly agree on everything I
love credit cards he hates credit cards
I love leveraging debt he hates
leveraging debt I like subscribing for
the YouTube algorithm all right we get
it anyways today we're sitting down with
this Protege George camel And discussing
the secrets behind why Dave Ramsey's
methods have been so successful at
helping people become millionaires on
average it takes people 18 to 24 months
to get out of all Consumer Debt
surprisingly it's pretty simple so it's
just the introduction to the new
philosophy exactly keep watching because
this is one of the best debt arguments
that we've ever had in the podcast and
you're really going to enjoy it I
promise but first we gotta thank our
sponsor optimizing my workflow is
seeming like a never-ending task I
honestly feel like I need software now
to start optimizing how I'm optimizing
my workflow but of course Graham of
course that was before I started using
today's sponsor bittrex24 bittrex24 is
an all-in-one platform that can replace
multiple software tools and streamline
your business with over 12 million users
worldwide bittrex 24 is currently the
most popular CRM and project management
tool and the best part is that it's
completely free to use you can manage
your projects tasks team team
Communications and more all in one place
with one of their over 35 free tools
from customer relationship management to
marketing automation there is something
for you regardless of how big or small
your business is and my personal
favorite Graham is the project
management calendar which has been an
absolute Game Changer in managing my
daily tasks it's available in the cloud
on mobile or for you techies as an open
source software that can be installed on
your own servers and is fully
customizable say goodbye to switching
between multiple tools or having to pay
for multiple subscriptions so try it for
free today using a link down below and
take your workflow to the next level for
good again the link is down below in the
description to get started today and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast welcome back to the iced coffee
hour I'm George camel great intro thank
you so much George for making this
happen I gave it my all yeah it was
incredible This Is Amazing by the way we
have this full crew right here every
time we come to the Ramsay headquarters
we are just treated you guys are VIP we
treat everyone like this but you guys
are extra special and the iced coffee
too it is lovely here we really
appreciate it well we love having you
guys thanks for coming back yeah we
didn't scare you away the first time no
apparently not I loved everything you
did with Dave was awesome thank you if
anyone hasn't watched all of that they
need to go back because it was some of
my favorite Dave Graham content ever wow
yo I'm glad we could bring you on
because we had an interesting discussion
the other night at dinner I thought you
would have had one credit card like
something you were like I'm gonna get
this guy he's surely just like he's got
to tell people not to use them but he's
got to have at least one right we were
paying for dinner and I thought okay you
could get like two to five percent cash
back it was when we were paying for
dinner but I was like looking through
his wallet he's like oh you got any
credit cards in here and no surprisingly
you did not so you reflect the the
Mantra of the company which is really
interesting I live out all the
principles and it's not like a what if
Dave checks my wallet no there's none of
that there's no we're not doing credit
checks here no one checks your wallet
when you apply it's just kind of the
honor System that if you work here you
actually believe in this stuff and so
I've I just celebrated today 10 years we
did a fun staff meeting announcement and
I got a little box of my little coins
for one year five year ten year and part
of that now announcement and celebration
was like this guy has Faithfully walked
out the principles for a decade now what
does that mean tent you celebrate 10
years like 10 years debt free taxes
really yeah so I've been on Dave's team
I started as a temp and an intern worked
in marketing social media email
marketing I never I didn't have any kind
of on-camera role until 2017. I had no
idea because I think I found you maybe
two years ago when I started seeing you
appear on the Ramsay show
but I had no idea you were here for that
long yeah I feel like I grew up here I
mean it's crazy I know you've been you
know when you start your career young it
just feels like you kind of mature like
when you get married definitely for you
grow up with your spouse and so I feel
like this place raised me in a sense I
met my wife here she still works here
really so this place like runs through
my veins and so I'm very passionate
about it and I love the principles and I
love getting to help people it's funny
even a lady at the front desk she said
she just celebrated 18 years at the
company so it seems like when people
start working here they just stay here I
mean once you find a good thing I mean
why go anywhere yeah you know so that
was my story so what tree to Ramsay did
you start off with debt like what was
your story behind that so when I started
at Ramsey as a temp and intern I was
thirty six thousand dollars in student
loan debt I had four thousand dollars in
credit card debt and I'd heard about
Financial Peace University I'd moved
from Boston uh Massachusetts to Mobile
Alabama and of course Dave has a heavier
presence in the South you know in the
Bible Belt Evangelical churches and all
that and so I had heard about FPU but I
didn't really know much more than like
oh he's a finance guy so what drew me
actually was a personality we had at the
time and I wanted to kind of work with
him and help him with Social Media stuff
I was a marketing guy I was a musician
and so I just loved helping other people
reach folks in a creative way and that
to me was what marketing is and so
that's kind of how I got my start here
was really through that personality and
then I was like oh I'm gonna go through
Financial Peace University as a new team
member and it changed everything like my
whole Paradigm changed and I realized
everything I know about money was wrong
like I was lied to like the system is
designed to keep you broke what do you
spend the money on on what you said you
were four thousand dollars in credit
card oh yeah oh my God what was that
about so I was a musician and so it was
a lot of just gear and camera gear I
love video editing I was going to go to
film school so you know you're like I
gotta have a DSLR because like what if I
want to start a YouTube channel and the
amp is a little old let's upgrade the
amp and so it was just stupid stuff and
gear and again
I opened a Discover card because it had
like rotating five percent cash back and
I was like that's a no-brainer right
deal right there and they had the
American Express Delta Sky miles cards
like well you know I want to travel and
see my family I can do right and all of
a sudden I'm carrying a balance of four
thousand dollars and I'm broke going
like but they they told me this is the
path like this is what's gonna get me
the free stuff and the cash back and so
at some point I was just like it's not
worth it and so I cut up the cards now
when you spent that money though I
assume you just didn't have the cash to
pay it off so what was your plan with
that just you're gonna put it on a card
did you expect to make enough money to
pay off
I'm not thinking that far it's always
the plan that you're gonna have the
money later to pay it all off at the end
of the month like when the bill comes
due I'm gonna have the money but as I
now know taking calls on the Ramsay show
every day it just doesn't always work
out like that life hits you there's an
emergency and most of the people who are
using the credit cards they don't have a
pile of cash in the bank to cover those
expenses and that was me you know I was
23 years old just getting started with
an entry level salary like I didn't have
much but you would spend some time in
College correct yes I graduated you
graduated what did you study I studied
communication because I wanted to go
into marketing and media and film and
that was about as close as I could get
and how'd you get your initial job at
the the Ramsey solution it was actually
through some Twitter DMs I was very
persistent tenacious you know much like
you guys a lot of hustle and I was just
like I want to work there I'll do
whatever it takes I'll do whatever you
want I'm here to just serve I want to be
there and what Drew you exactly to it
you said it was a personality but what
was it specifically
um I think it was you know me coming out
of I grew up Arabic Baptist which is
very strange if you know anything about
the Middle East and religion you know
people like you weren't Muslim but
growing up in the in this Arabic Baptist
bubble of Boston I came from this
Evangelical background and I love the
way
this personality brought kind of faith
and humor and heart altogether and it's
a lot of what we do here you know a lot
of faith a lot of humor a lot of heart
and that's that's Dave in a nutshell
it's so entertaining so that's what
really drew me to this place is just
kind of seeing someone with a really
inspiring message presented in a
creative way so you were a casual viewer
turned hardcore fan turned I want to
work with this guy so you DM them a
bunch on Twitter and then you made it
work yeah and that turned into well let
me get in touch with another person and
that became let's get a call with HR and
it was like let's try to find a way to
make this work because you know they
don't you can't be an intern if you
already graduated from college so it
became how do we get an intern well
let's make him a temp so they found a
temp role for me in social media and so
that all sort of percolated into a
full-time role months later interesting
and you were in poor financial standing
when you first started working here did
they take that into consideration at the
time do you tell them like hey like I
got student loans I got 4K of credit
card debt there's not like a money
confessional during the interview
process but they do uh ask you to do a
budget which I know you guys are you
know not the biggest budgeters as I
heard from Caleb this guy's a big
budgeter I'm I was a big budgeter not so
much anymore so yeah part of the budget
is just to go like hey we want to make
sure that what you need to make it is
enough and that our salary that we can
offer you is going to cover that because
what you don't want is someone to start
working here and all of a sudden they're
like I can't even make this work and
with people coming in with a whole bunch
of debt it can be tough
and so it's I think it's a really cool
part of the process to just go like do a
budget and for some people they may be
doing it for the first time no so they
look at the income that they're about to
to pay and say can you can you live off
this income essentially I mean it's it's
a very
basically I actually really like that
that is inside I like that a lot and
it's not to like pry into your finances
and it's all about your income it's just
going what are your expenses and we want
to make sure that this makes sense for
you financially this would be
interesting there's this clip that's
gone viral lately you probably have seen
it of JP uh the CEO Jamie dimon from
JPMorgan Chase uh was speaking with an
employee who's making or or she was
talking about someone making 16.25 cents
an hour uh going in debt I think she was
in the red four or five hundred dollars
a month working this job at JPMorgan
Chase and they wanted her to be making
more money and it was just a really
interesting clip you should react to
this
um but I think had they done a budget on
that it would have been very apparent
right at the very beginning that this is
not the right job for her to be able to
pay her expenses well you guys know this
I mean a lot of people are out there
they're hurting from inflation and the
housing market and interest rates and
like life feels impossible but when I
dig into people's finances generally
it's not the egg prices that are
actually keeping us broke it's the debt
payments and I did a man on the street
the other day in downtown Nashville and
this girl's like I have to live with my
parents I don't I'm like how much do you
make she's like I make eighty thousand
dollars
I was like and you can't move out she's
like no I was like well what's what's
happening in your finances how much debt
do you have what does it add up to a
month I have two thousand dollars
in payments a month on just Consumer
Debt and so I was like well if you
didn't have two thousand dollars in debt
you would have two thousand more dollars
to budget and use to live your life and
afford rent and so it's very clear to me
that debt is a huge problem with this
generation especially we'll get on to
the debt debate right at the end that's
a retention hack everyone so stay until
the end exactly and you're gonna review
some of Jack spending hats yeah I can't
potentially do a little audit on Me
Maybe Grand two if he's open to it but
only four things on that list here's
what Graham spent in the last month
exactly but let's get on to uh your your
start here at Ramsey so you started out
what'd you say you were doing marketing
yes I was a social media marketer email
marketing coordinator so I was in
marketing for my first four years here
and FPU is not mandatory to go through
as a new employee here but it is it's
suggested or it's it's it is it's part
if you haven't gone through it it's part
of the onboarding process so there's a
few books that we want you to read some
of them are books some of them just
books that Dave loves leadership books
and then part of that is if you haven't
gone through Financial Peace University
you've got to go through it because this
is our Flagship money course this is our
principles in a nutshell and so if you
haven't gone through that you've got to
know what we're about in Financial Peace
University is just the best way to do
that it's nine lessons over nine weeks
and you can go through it locally I went
through it with a local class at a
church here which was really cool yeah
how did that change your views on money
well I grew up the way a lot of people
grew up thinking like you know watching
my parents who are immigrants immigrated
from the Middle East and they just
conformed to this American money culture
which was well you gotta have a good car
and you know it's probably going to take
a loan to do that you've got to have a
house so you got to get a big mortgage
and you know you got to get the credit
score so you got to open up the credit
cards and get all your lines of credit
going
and that is how you make it financially
what's funny is no other country lives
like this with the obsession of debt the
obsession of the credit score and so I
fell for those same traps growing up
and so what changed for me going through
Financial Peace University was number
one realizing that debt is Like A New
Concept this has not been around our
grandma didn't play with debt the way we
do in today's society and so realizing
debt is not my friend the system is
designed to keep you broke and even
better there's a way to rise above it
all and you don't have to live with this
kind of stress playing this Wild game
before we go into that we talk a lot
about financial success here on the
channel but what's even more important
is the mental aspect and health along
the way and today's sponsor betterhelp
is here to help you out with both
betterhelp isn't a crisis line nor is it
self-help it's the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
over 30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists in their Network they offer
help for a wide range of issues so I've
personally been using betterhelp for the
last month now and I honestly started it
to make sure that it was something I was
comfortable promoting but honestly over
the four sessions I've taken I did not
expect how much it would have actually
helped my mental health you can talk to
your therapist by text chat phone or
video call and you can even and message
your therapist at any time or schedule
live sessions when it's convenient for
you and plus if for any reason your
therapist isn't the right fit you can
switch to a new therapist at no
additional charge with better help you
get the same professionalism and quality
as you would expect from an in-office
therapy session except with a therapist
who's custom picked for you so if you're
interested in getting started with
betterhelp visit the link Down Below in
the description or go to betterhelp.com
iced coffee hour to get 10 off your
first month of therapy thanks again to
betterhelp for sponsoring this episode
and back to the podcast can we talk
about the nine steps really quickly
because I'm a failure I think with a
couple of them but can you go through
them yeah so are you done with the seven
baby steps uh you just said there was
nine steps to the oh there's nine
courses let's do the seven baby steps so
here's the Ramsay baby steps in a
nutshell baby step number one thousand
dollar starter emergency fund so this is
just a little buffer between you and
life and we found that four in ten
people have zero dollars in savings and
so this is a huge milestone just to have
a thousand bucks in the bank for most
most Americans once you have that
thousand bucks you move on to baby step
two and you do these in focused with
Focus intensity in order can I could I
raise a point of contention right there
because I was on Caleb Hammer's thing
right I saw this special audit yes and
he said that Dave claims or he's proud
that he hasn't changed his philosophy in
like 30 some years or something like
that and Caleb said if I hadn't changed
my philosophy in 30 some years that's
not something I would necessarily be
proud of and this was directly related
to that step a thousand dollar emergency
fund which over time especially with
inflation has became a lot less value no
was it a thousand dollars thirty years
ago
really it's always been a thousand so
what oh like actually that would be
about two to three thousand yeah so how
long until that 1000 gets changed to
something else 2048 no I'm just kidding
because I'm wondering here's the
funniest it's gonna be diluted to
basically like a lollipop yeah we're
thinking about this in terms of math
right of like well a thousand dollars
thirty years ago three thousand dollars
now but it was never about math because
truthfully a thousand bucks even back
then with a true emergency still
wouldn't cover it and so the idea of
baby step one is not to have a
mathematical number that covers your
emergencies it's to light a fire under
you
to actually attack the deck because if
we said hey it's five thousand dollars
for baby step one most people are gonna
fall off the wagon now you guys are
sharp guys you would knock that out for
most people that we talk to that's a big
struggle they need a quick win and the
second thing it does is it actually does
cover all the ankle biter emergencies
like when you think about a lot of the
emergencies in your life it's not
necessarily the HVAC and the five
thousand dollar car repair it's the 200
bucks you to pay to the plumber or in
your case maybe the locksmith
you know it's those kinds of things and
so a lot of it is mental fear of like
you know and you guys you're you're
willing to take a lot more risk
financially than I am and so the
thousand dollars the fact that scares
you but you're so willing to take risks
in other places there's just a mental
hurdle to get past where you go I'm
gonna get a thousand dollars and I'm
gonna follow this proven plan because it
works and that's the wild part is it it
feels like it's not enough
and yet millions of people do it and I
go oh I survived I made it sure that's
actually really interesting it's not a
long-term thing because remember baby
step two when we tell people to get out
of debt on average it takes people 18 to
24 months to get out of all Consumer
Debt huh and so then you fully fund that
emergency fund for three to six months
of expenses which is you know widely
regarded as the right number yeah so
it's just the introduction to the new
philosophy exactly okay this is not
meant to be a long-term savings okay
let's go into just a buffer the next
couple steps so this one I'm sure you'll
have contention here too I don't know
baby step two pay off all Consumer Debt
using the debt snowball method okay
what's the snowball method so the
snowball method means we are looking at
all the balances and ignoring the
interest rate I know Grant just go with
me okay go with me Define logic I'm
really trying it delete the interest
rates out of your head look at the
balances pay off pay all minimum
payments on all of those balances except
for the smallest one
and with that smallest one we are
attacking it with a Vengeance everything
you can sell side jobs any margin you
can create by slashing expenses we throw
onto that smallest debt and what does
that do well it speeds up the process
and so that that gets knocked out we
free up a payment so now we can apply
all the margin we had plus that payment
they got freed up towards the next debt
and so you can see the snowball gets
more snow as it rolls down the hill so
it sounds like the baby steps aren't
attacking like Financial instability
from the most advantageous angle but
it's more so doing it from like fixing
the psychology of financially broken
people oh yeah we say all the time that
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge we all know what
to do right we all know not to go into
credit card debt and not to overspend
and to live on less than we make but
it's so hard to do and so when it comes
to getting out of debt we can't go in
the same way to get out and so it's got
to take Behavior change and sacrifice
and Grandma you you uh you've said this
in one of your past Clips were reacted
to that living on less than you made is
one of the best financial decisions
you've ever made yeah Dave Ramsey is
really a therapist is what what I've
realized that is a hard pill for me to
swallow because I'm like I just feel
like you gotta do like the financially
smart thing if you're just looking at
the numbers but it actually makes the
thing is actually it makes a lot of
sense there's a lot of emotion I know
you know it's a lot of logic but there's
so much emotion tied up with money
that's subconscious that we don't really
think about talk about but think about
every purchase you've made there was
some emotion tied to it some of it was
necessity right you have to pay the
light bill but some of it is just like I
saw it I want it I'm gonna get it that's
most of our consumer culture today I
feel like two for Dave if you're
speaking to a room of a thousand people
probably 900 of them yes have a have a
behavior problem
and maybe a hundred people would would
do better with the with the Avalanche
method you know which is let's attach
the highest a highest interest rate but
for 900 of those people they'd be better
off just starting with the bottom and
working their way up that's what I
brought up to Dave on the first time and
I'll ask you that question at the end of
the episode Another retention hack uh
but let's go on to the third baby step
okay so baby step three once we have all
of our debt paid off all Consumer Debt
we have a thousand bucks in the bank
saved now we go back and fully fund that
emergency fund with three to six months
of expenses okay not income but expenses
so Bare Bones expenses what would it
take if you guys lost all of your income
and you had to survive
for three to six months and so that part
on average takes our folks about six
months to do okay I like it so all in on
this plan from having a pile of debt to
being debt free with money in the bank
to cover emergencies we're talking two
and a half years which for most people
sounds like a long time yeah like if
you're 24 years old you're going to I'm
going to be a grown adult by then it's
27. but two and a half years is going to
be here whether you like it or not so
the question is do you want to remain
broke because you thought you were a
financial genius or do you want to have
no payments in the world with a pile of
money to cover you and so it's a freeing
thing when you get to that point sure I
like that yeah and then what's after
that so then we can start talking about
investing and so here's the problem when
we talk about baby step two this is
gonna grind your gears we say to pause
all investing including your employer
match
when you're getting out of debt I did
not know it was including employer match
everything
down to zero we gotta think most likely
that employer match is not going to be
that big in the big picture compared to
paying off debt right now I mean we're
talking to be better you're pausing your
three percent match for two years
but when you come back here's the thing
I found most people are only investing
up to the match because that's all they
can afford yeah they're broke so we go
hey what if two and a half years from
now instead of investing three percent
you can invest 15 percent
so we 5xed our investment contributions
at that point yeah you're gonna make up
for lost time the problem is most people
stay doing 17 things at once and 20
years later they're still doing 17
things at once and haven't made the
progress they wanted yeah it's probably
better to focus on fewer things get
really good at like just I gotta do
these three things and that's it that's
the plan so baby steps one through three
Focus intensity one at a time baby steps
four five and six you actually do at the
same time but they're still in that
order so they're still priority four
comes before five but it's a plate that
you get spinning and then you move on to
the next one so baby step four is
fifteen percent of your household income
into retirement accounts have you found
that 15 is like the magic number why not
20. because I feel like 15 I think if
you say 15 of your income I think the
average retirement is like 45 years is
how much it takes you to be able to
replace your income yeah we've found you
know there's been different numbers
people some people say okay if you're
not doing 20 at least with inflation
everything go going on like you're not
gonna be able to retire but what we
found is the reason 15 is a sweet spot
is because it allows you to have some
margin to do baby steps five and six
which is college and early mortgage
payoff because if you do 20 there's not
a lot of room left to help your kid go
to college debt free if they choose to
do so not a lot of room left to pay off
the mortgage early which then frees you
up later in life sure
okay so that's where we go hey 15 into
we say match beats Roth beats
traditional so that's the investing
strategy in a nutshell uh no secrets
here you want to get that match first
because that's 100 return on your
investment then move on to Roth because
we love the tax-free growth for most
people uh you know if you're younger
Roth is going to be a better option for
the long term and then you can move on
to traditional got it okay so that's
five and six and then the final one so
five would be saving for college and
that one's it that varies again because
some people don't go to college some
people
um might be late for them but put money
away in a 529 plane for example because
college is getting more expensive and so
if your kid does choose to go to college
and that's the right path for them it's
hard for a kid at 18 to have a hundred
thousand dollars saved and so to have a
parent get ahead of that and we've we've
done a whole documentary on this called
borrowed future that's free on YouTube
and I hosted a podcast series with the
same name and we dug into this crisis
about like how did we get here the
entire student loan industry is a giant
scam and they decided they can just
raise prices because people are willing
to take out debt to pay for it and so
the whole thing got real muddy real
quick and here we are 1.7 trillion
dollars in student loan debt yeah with
45 million what was the conclusion on
that why is college so expensive why are
the costs going up so much it started
with a lot of good intentions from the
government to kind of get in bed with
the student loan companies and go we
should make this federally backed and
all of a sudden it became like this is a
money pumping machine for Sallie Mae
and so if they raise the prices people
go well okay we'll just take out more
student loan debt and the government's
backing this yeah this is a good idea
and so that became a cycle where the
student loan companies are making record
profits every year the students as as
you guys know like the wages didn't go
up 500 percent and so they're leaving
still making 40 50 Grand but now they
have 200 000 of student loan debt and
what did we tell our kids growing up get
good grades get good SAT scores so you
can go to the College of your dreams
regardless of what it costs and so that
all of a sudden you have 45 million
people fall into this trap of student
loan debt which I think we could all
argue is not uh the greatest form of
debt as far as Roi some people I agreed
it's great they they'll if you're going
to be a doctor and you're going to go
make three four hundred thousand dollars
there's some pretty clear math you could
do to say like there's Roi on this but
going and getting like a liberal studies
degree and going like well I was told
the degree is the path I mean you guys
know that degrees do not equal success
and as we go further in time that is
more and more true and so that's a huge
part of Saving for college and then baby
step six is paying off the mortgage
early
again there's no parameters on this we
found that people who follow our plan
end up paying off their mortgage in
about seven years and the average
millionaire from our study pays it off
in about 10 years it's tough for me at
like a 2.875 30-year fixed I remember
the last time 2.875 yeah what are you
2.874 oh well yeah what's the same thing
I just round up that's a win that's a
win for a boy Jack yeah it's the point
like nine nine basically I just it's
rounded okay so we're arguing over like
an extra two dollars a month it's
something like that well mine's the same
I just I round the same yeah so here's a
question because I know you bought your
first rental property in cash I did why
not take out a mortgage to do that I
tried oh and then yeah I got denied
because I didn't have a credit card and
that and believe it or you have a credit
score this is an interesting discussion
right yeah yeah so that was one of my
biggest regrets that's what actually
really got me into credit cards to begin
with you were like I had I'm not not
gonna fall for this I have no debt I
paid everything with cash and I saved so
at the time I think I was 20 years old
give her take I had like 120 Grand saved
up in cash I bought everything with cash
I bought my car cash I used a debit card
on everything I was so proud it's like I
had no debt and I've never needed to
borrow money for anything I was so proud
of that so when I wanted to go and buy a
property I spoke with several mortgage
uh Brokers all of them were like if you
don't have a credit card you need you
need a co-signer I couldn't get a
co-signer because my parents did not
have a good uh credit score at the time
yeah who wants to Coastline for a 20
year old's mortgage and that's scary oh
yeah totally so I couldn't get any sort
of cosigner my grandma offered but she
was Grandma but she was Canadian and
there was a big issue having a Canadian
cosign on my mortgage as an American so
couldn't do that and so I had to buy the
property cash but I went several routes
I think one lender offered me it was
like an eight or nine percentage like it
was so high it just didn't make sense
for me to take so I bought a cash and
after that I vowed I'm gonna get a
credit score a credit card I'm gonna
build up my credit score I'm gonna make
a huge change here and so now that's why
I'm like such an advocate of like hey
get a credit card build your credit
score you could do it for free it's
really easy and now I've got like an 805
credit score anywhere I want to get
money from I get it at the lowest
interest rate but do you have money like
you have enough money that you never
need to borrow money in a sense in a
sense but it makes it makes sense of my
tax bracket though because I could use
everything as a deduction this is like
the Kiyosaki like well that's not taxed
it's the ultimate wealth hack pretty
much but if I'm looking to buy a
property whatever uh debt I have against
that property is just to write off
against the rental income so already it
knocks off like 40 percent of what I
would be paying so like I say 40 just
taking out debt on that um your
discussion with Dave on this when you
showed him all your properties and
you're like hey what would you change
and he was like I mean I'd pay off all
the mortgages it's like just to reduce
risk it's not mathematically in the
picture here but yeah when it comes to
the interest rate and I actually did a
no credit score mortgage back in 2019
successfully so I just want to say that
it can be done and it wasn't it wasn't
that hard honestly I was kind of shocked
at how easy it was you know you submit a
bunch of documents your tax return 12
months of rental history uh proof of
payments like Insurance cell phone bills
and well they've gotten better about it
I've seen but this was back in 2010. a
lot of those things they weren't taking
into account cell phone payments utility
bills things like this yeah and
Churchill Mortgage which we've you know
has been an Advertiser with Dave for
decades right now they're they're like
the number one in the industry and so
they walk you through the whole process
and I did a 15 year and we actually ran
the numbers on this because a lot of
people I posted a video that went viral
on Tick Tock and it got so much hate but
people are like Well yeah if you want a
49 interest rate you can try that guy's
method and I was like I got the same
rate that someone with excellent credit
would have gotten so we ran the numbers
on this with some of the mortgage loan
officers there and it turns out if you
do a 15-year fixed rate mortgage which
is the only mortgage we recommend at
Ramsey and you do at least 10 percent
down which we always recommend 10 down
then you would have the same exact
interest rate as someone with excellent
credit on a what on a 15 or on a 15 year
with 10 down you have the same rate and
so that argument was just debunked with
actual data from from the mortgage
quotes but it's an interesting topic
because I was you know you're kind of
worried like when you want to be a
homeowner and there's one thing in your
way and that's the credit score it's
scary but having the data in front of
you to go okay I need 12 months rental
history most people are going to have
that I paid I've paid my insurance and
cell phone bills on time I have my tax
return I can get a mortgage and it could
also be just as easy to get like a
secured credit card a 300 limit you know
put a few charges on the card every
month that you would spend anyway like
put your gas on the card like every time
you go to the gas station put it on the
car sure paid off in full if they even
like immediately afterwards when it
posts pay it off yeah there's a lot of
ways to skin that cat but I found if
you're if you're going through the whole
Ramsey plan from start to finish when
we're like hey do a plusectomy and cut
up the credit card and close the
accounts there is a finality to the
breakup that is also very freeing to go
like I don't have to keep up with what's
the latest credit I mean I love your
your videos like the one you know here's
the five best credit cards to get in
2023 and here's the ones here's the
rotating cashback and if restaurants
this month are five percent I'm like but
the whole point is we're trying to limit
our expenses and be intentional and be
on a budget so getting five percent back
on eating out which is something that's
going to cost you way more than yeah
eating at home it kind of negates the
cost especially when you go if you carry
a balance you're now at 24 APR if you
don't pay it off in full but my thought
is that if you're going to a restaurant
anyway you may as well save five percent
so if you're gonna do it yeah which
again like very controversial take from
Dave is you shouldn't be eating out if
you're trying to aggressively really pay
off Consumer Debt yeah like and as
someone who you know we're both pretty
Frugal guys like it is unwise to go out
and spend 30 40 bucks on you know we
went out and it was like there's a 20
gratuity automatic there's a 15 liquor
tax on top of the tax if you've got a
cocktail or you just don't drink exactly
there's another life hack and so all of
a sudden you go there's no way this is
this is cheaper than eating at home and
so the whole idea of like eating at home
and I get people are like well your time
you know I saw the Alex harmosi clip
where he's like you should never eat at
home your idiot if you eat at home you
should always be eating out like your
time is worth so much more I'm like for
most people their time isn't worth that
much more like he's talking to them he's
making millions of dollars yeah right
most people watching this they're making
14 an hour going hermosie told me I
should never eat at home I'm losing
money and so there's a lot of
debate in that Circle as well but on the
credit card side I just don't miss it I
mean I legitimately you've seen my
wallet it's just the Apple wallet and I
have one card in your wallet right now I
just have my one I have my bank card and
my license that is it you can see here
I'm not going to show you the card
number yeah sure but there's my license
and my debit card and it's you can see
it says debit that's true verify I feel
like a magician being like yeah
but that's it and it's been such a
freeing life because I used to have you
know multiple cards of which one should
I use what's going to be the best for
cash back and the mental energy I was
spending and then going am I utilizing
the rewards to their full potential and
we talked about this the other night
about like what it what is the actual
dollar value
you can assign and for people who are
making crazy money and they've got the
fanciest Amex cards like you're
utilizing all the value because you are
super intentional for most people
they're collecting the airline miles
they're like I don't know how many miles
this is because it's not actual Air
Miles you have 40 000 miles you're like
that feels like a lot that'll get you to
Boise one way if you're lucky from
Nashville and so a lot of people aren't
doing the math on what these rewards are
actually costing them
and if it's actually worth it yeah I
think we added up mine I was guessing
about twenty five hundred dollars a year
Annual fees is that taken out of that
um because like the AMX ones have you
know some high high annual fees I
believe that's including the annual fees
and so I was like could I show Graham
how to save two thousand dollars in a
year just by budgeting and being super
intentional with expenses I think I
could it'd be a fun experiment if anyone
out there is willing to try it well also
you have to think for for 2500 bucks if
you spent that time that you were
studying like all the rotating fees and
I don't study it's it's just like a
study he skipped that part nothing to
study on this it's just like well for
most people's cars most people's reward
cards it's a different scenario versus
what you're doing and so for most people
and also their income when you look at
the income ratio to the rewards they're
getting it's just not worth it you know
two percent cash back let's say that's
the number and you make fifty thousand
dollars well after taxes and after what
you can actually put on the card most
you can spend on that card is what 20
grand in a year depends on the card yeah
so let's say two percent on 20 grand
is it worth it for 400 bucks
well I mean to play that for a free
credit card like the city double cash is
that example it's just two percent cash
back on anything you spend money on so
from my perspective everything is two
percent cheaper assuming but you don't
spend money off how does this work well
I'm gonna spend money on something right
sure so it's like if I could get two
percent cash back on everything then it
adds up I'm just a free card most like
obviously the people that we're talking
to very different audience sure you were
talking to people who are looking to
maximize their wealth I'm talking to
people who are like really struggling
yeah like they're hurting they're not
making a lot of money they're not making
hundred thousand I would agree to get
from zero to one I think that makes the
most sense if you're a multi-millionaire
too you're gonna be okay anyways if
you're a multi-millionaire but for the
people we're talking to they're teachers
they make 40 Grand and they heard from
everyone around them that credit cards
are the path the credit score is the
path and we're just trying to help free
them so that they can retire one day
then it just goes like what is in my way
that could stop me from doing that and
the risk of 24 APR is not worth the
reward of two percent so I saw a great
reaction I believe it was you and Ken
who did this one the person who was uh
having a wedding and they said here's a
life hack you can put all of your
expenses on the credit card and now we
got a free trip and we got our honeymoon
paid for with credit card points I'm
looking at that and I'm thinking that's
fantastic that's a a great choice
because if you're gonna if the budget is
let's say twenty thousand dollars you
can open up three to four credit cards
get the sign up bonus on all of them
that's a free trip free airfare free
Hotel you know what's more expensive the
marriage counseling when you start your
your marriage off with sixty thousand
dollars in credit okay at twenty four
percent let's just assume okay sixty
thousand I don't know if that was the
exact amount that they were spending you
could probably do that on ten to fifteen
thousand dollars get a totally free
honeymoon paid for just by opening up
the cards getting the sign up bonus
let's say 15 grand if you're gonna spend
fifteen thousand dollars anyway and
you're intentional about it that's a
free trip that's a free honeymoon so
it's saving you money at the end of the
day well I got a free wedding so I can't
talk but most people when it comes to
weddings they're way overspending and so
if it's your money if it's Graham's
money from his bank account from his
debit card you're gonna look at that
wedding very differently you're going
let's actually like get quotes from
multiple florists and see like what you
know and like you may be entering the
space soon where it's like we got to
start planning for this thing and I'm
not trying to spend 80 grand on a
wedding to throw a party for other
people
and so it changes how you make decisions
when you use your own money and that's
honestly the biggest reason I advocate
for debit cards over credit cards
because it changed mentally it's
different when it's coming out of your
bank instantly you treat that
differently than well I'll pay this off
at the end of the month in bulk I think
we're getting very nuanced here Graham's
trying to pull up specific examples and
numbers and everything exactly why it's
better and you're providing the
psychology yeah behind it all right so I
think the the fundamental difference
here is that Graham thinks that if you
are someone that's very diligent with
their money you go through your
statements and you're intentional about
everything
um and you can remove your emotions from
your finances then yes it's there's a
net positive and you're saying probably
right probably well most people think
they're that person is the problem we
all put ourselves in that bucket of like
yeah well I'm the type of person I'll
never have a balance on my credit card
and we're 987 billion dollars in credit
card debt as a nation average credit
card debt six grand a person and so like
everyone started that Journey only going
well yeah I'm not going to be that guy
and all of a sudden you're that guy at
24 interest and you're calling our show
and you're like I'm 130 000 in credit
card debt at 22 interest well I feel
like a lot of those are people who spent
money they didn't have to begin with
like if you know I have five thousand
dollars in my savings account but I'm
saying but no I think a lot of people
just put the money in the card expecting
like I could make the minimum payment
it's not going to be that bad I'll think
about it for me you know a year from now
I think very few people see I have five
thousand dollars in savings I'm gonna
spend two thousand dollars anyway I'm
gonna put it on the card and pay it off
immediately I have a feeling a lot of
people say I have a thousand dollars in
cash I have a 5 000 thing I'm gonna
spend money on let me just put on the
card and pay it off later I'll say this
I don't think I would be a net worth
millionaire today if I still had my
credit cards I think using a debit card
change my mentality and it changed my
goals to where it caused me to spend way
more intentionally be on a budget and
win more when it comes to money and
speed up that process can you admit if
you have technically on paper somebody
who can do every single thing right and
play the game they would be better off
financially using credit they can
benefit from it and that's true like I'm
not saying there's people out there who
you know people who have become
Millionaires and they don't have debt
and they have emergency funds who they
can use credit cards and pay them off
every month and they're going to be fine
and I'm not mad at anyone who uses
credit cards I'll be friends with you
all day long but the the data is too
clear to me and not just the data but
the reality of it because we take the
brunt of
people who are struggling that everyone
has the mentality that they're not going
to be that guy but then life hits and
they become that guy and so you know the
credit card Awards I just looked into uh
Capital one's financial statements for
2022 because another angle on this is
who is paying for the rewards
and a lot of people are like well The
Interchange fees you know when you go
and you spend money it's you know three
percent is charged to the business and
that gets passed on in rewards I looked
at the numbers and capital one's Revenue
15 over 15 billion came from interest
which is people who couldn't pay the
balance interest and fees only about 6
billion came from the other Revenue
through interchange and so about
two-thirds of the rewards mathematically
is paid for by people who are hurting
and struggling and paying interest
and so you're not a bad person if you
reap their Awards but for me personally
like it just feels icky to me like I
don't want to support A system that
operates in that way I think also
there's a little level of confirmation
bias between YouTube because just the
people you surround yourself by everyone
that calls in has basically been
demolished by credit and everything but
Graham and I on the other hand like the
people that we associate with a lot of
the people we decide just a part of our
our Circle you know like they've done it
extremely well and it's benefited them a
ton so I think there's also just a
difference in in culture in the people
oh absolutely yeah I mean you guys are
you're speaking to this percentage of
people who are like the Uber Finance
nerds we are talking to like every
American all walks of life you come to
us we're going to help you and that's
the thing is like our plan works for
everyone it may not be the fastest as
far as like could you go in the lottery
tomorrow and could you get really good
at playing stocks you could but the
chances of you getting burnt on that
versus winning in the long term is much
higher and so that's where we just go I
I'm not a risk guy and I want to win as
stupid as I am I still want to win
financially and so I love that this plan
works for people across the Spectrum
yeah can you walk us through your net
worth from when you started here to now
because you mentioned being a net worth
millionaire but then starting off with
debt could you walk us through that
process and uh like your net worth by
age if that makes sense yeah I'm trying
to think I didn't like track it
methodically but when I started at
Ramsey I had a negative net worth of you
know negative 40 Grand in the whole
between my student loans and my credit
cards and I didn't have much to my name
um you know I had like a little two
thousand dollar 401K that I rolled over
from when I was at Apple
and a few stocks that I ended up selling
to get out of debt faster oh really
quick you mentioned that you had 13
shares I had 13 share I looked at the
splits because I knew you'd ask yep
those 13 shares were worth about seven
or eight grand when I sold them if I had
held on to them two today they would be
worth a little over 50 Grand yep
so you were asking does that hurt in
hindsight I was like I don't look at
hindsight of what could have been sure
you know it's like a relationship like
what could have been but honestly
becoming debt free that much faster I
think it was a it was a wash as far as
the result okay to get out of debt
faster get the emergency fund faster
begin investing faster I feel like it
was still worth it I would do it all
over again but as far as net worth I was
negative forty thousand dollars in the
hole back in uh 2013 when I started and
2023 here we are and I have a net worth
of almost 1.1 million how is that
comprised is that a house Investments
like what's the breakdown of that so I
am very heavily weighted towards
mortgage because we me and my wife who
again works here when we got married we
both started off completely debt free in
our marriage I had already paid off all
my debt we had the emergency fund we had
already both built up savings and so we
were able to put down 45 percent on our
modest town home in Nashville wow and so
that allowed us to have a smaller
mortgage of 165. which we then
aggressively paid over 26 months and so
26 months later we're completely debt
free as you know we live in one of the
wealthiest counties in the nation here
in in Williamson County in Tennessee and
so the house appreciation as you know in
the last few years skyrocketed
and so that is a huge part of our net
worth
so we're waiting about
um at least two-thirds in house
currently and then the other third
between my wife and I it's basically
just our 401 case
and you know we have we have our cars
which aren't worth that much
um but aside from that you know you guys
we were talking at dinner and it was
like you really don't have single stocks
you really don't have any crypto I was
like I'm so boring I literally just have
a 401k I have an IRA that was a rollover
yeah that has the same uh Diversified
mutual funds as my 401k and my wife
invest the same exact way through her
Roth 401k and we are as boring as it
gets when it comes to that how confident
are you with your own personal finances
like what's your relationship with
Financial Security just the feeling of
it right oh I would say on that front
security wise I feel better than I've
ever felt in my life as far as Financial
Security and part of that is you know
just living a debt-free life it removes
that piece of the brain that's going
like you're not okay you're not safe and
I know you guys that part of your brain
was removed long ago like you're you're
totally okay well like as far as far as
like mortgages and risk and obviously
real estate versus if all of that real
estate debt was in crypto you might be
losing sleeping oh yeah but you're very
comfortable with real estate you're a
savant when it comes to real estate and
so you understand what you're invested
in but as far as Financial Security I
feel great about retirement and again
I'm not trying to do like the you know
there's the fire movement and I'm not
trying to retire at 35. that's not a
goal for me especially as someone who's
married has a family you know we just
have different goals and so I'm like I
love what I do I want to be here for the
next 20 years and so I'm totally okay
okay with my 401k slowly growing in
Balance over time over the next 20 years
versus I need to make a half million
dollars in the next five years or else
I'm screwed on my plan and so it's I
have a long longer term Horizon longer
term game plan if the folks that are
doing fire they want to retire in the
next five years you've got to be wildly
aggressive
and how secure do you feel financially
Graham like what's your relationship
with your own
um I feel like I'm it sounds stupid
probably 75 secure but a lot of it I
think like what the worst case scenario
I I think to myself stocks going down 50
at the same time there's like some sort
of lawsuit that happens at the same time
as like you know I don't know I think of
like if if like let's say an earthquake
hits Los Angeles and it's like the one
and insurance payouts aren't like enough
and it all happens at the same time real
estate crashes your Investments crash
yeah yeah and you still have a cash cash
position I do which that's a big hedge
for you right but I'm like if everything
happens at once how do I insulate myself
from that like I have insurances and
stuff like that we get calls like that
on the show where people are like hey I
saw the news and like should I pull out
all my money out of the stock market
what if it all goes down to zero I'm
like if you're saying every company goes
bankrupt in America we're not going to
be worried about our investment accounts
we're going to be shooting each other
for water you know what I mean so like
that is an apocalyptic I Am Legend
scenario that I just don't entertain and
I have a lot of faith in the American
economy that you know capitalism and
Innovation will always cause us to
prosper over the long term yeah and so
if you let you know you've looked at the
stock market dips in hindsight it was
like oh there's a small bump in the road
but when you're in it it feels like
you're being jostled in a roller coaster
I'm just really risk adverse when it
comes to like I I like to maintain and
conserve wealth didn't necessarily try
to like maximize or build it so I look
at like what's the worst possible case
scenario that could happen at the same
time and how do I prepare myself for
that that makes sense so like that's
kind of how I plan everything it's like
how can I maintain this current
lifestyle assuming everything goes to
zero and the market crashes and we get
an earthquake in LA and my insurance
doesn't cover it at the same time I get
hit with something like that's what I
plan for as stupid as it is because it
makes me sleep at night knowing that
like no matter what happens it's okay
you're gonna be okay yes the only thing
that that I see with you say saying what
can I do to maintain or preserve this
current lifestyle yeah is the fact that
whatever your current lifestyle is is
constantly changing it's like back when
you were in Santa Monica that was the
current lifestyle you drove the Tesla
that was that's how you lived and then
you moved to Las Vegas and then you
bought this New Vegas house and so
you're maintaining that mortgage payment
as well as the ones nothing else I want
well then then you bought a Ford GT and
then you bought an aquarium and then you
bought this and it's like the lifestyle
the current lifestyle is it's not I mean
obviously it will always be current
because that's the only thing that
exists but also like it's changing it's
always Dynamic I'd say there's nothing
else that I want the only thing I would
like at some point is uh have a slightly
bigger home for a bigger office uh and
more backyard space that's it that's the
only thing I could think of but
comparatively to the average consumer
you were actually like the least flashy
as far as you know most people with your
level of wealth they are really showy
and most people who even want to Aspire
to where you want to be they're going
out every weekend they're spending at
the bars they're buying the nicest
clothes whereas you've decided I'm I'm
gonna actually swim upstream against a
lot of that and so the things you buy
they're very rare and they're super
intentional yeah and you've talked about
the Ford GT and like the cars and the
watch they make money
is up 30 Jack that's impressive better
than the stock market should have
invested in
now that could be a that could be your
new business model you can invest in
grams purchases
yeah I would buy I would love to do that
if I could get a good deal right now in
an SLS AMG that's the car what's a good
deal on something like that uh 150 and
below for a low mileage under 18K SLS
AMG preferably silver there's a hey if
you're out there and you've got that
Graham's your guy you got a deal the
thing I'm noticing is that you have this
peace of mind kind of with regards to
finances and this confidence and
optimism about you that I really like
and I'm like okay that peace of mind
seems like it's invaluable like I would
love to have that Financial deep-rooted
Security that you have now of course
Graham is killing it financially I see
him like oh it'd be kind of nice to yeah
I'm probably can we just say I'm
probably the poorest rich person that's
ever been on your show I mean as far as
like most people that are that you guys
are talking to they're like insanely
successful and so I hope I'm the poster
child for anyone who like works on
normal like they work for a company and
they have a 401k it's possible for them
too without having to like be the
biggest creators and entrepreneurs of
all time but you're talking like
directly tied to the financial success
when I'm kind of talking about just like
overall fulfillment and like oh yeah
like you know I mean confidence with
with regards we talk about financial
peace a lot and obviously we have a deep
Faith background in that
um and and Dave talks about this at the
end of every show
he mentions this as a part a big part of
what we do and it's a deep why behind it
and you know I just feel more
financially peaceful knowing the faith
background and reading the Bible and
seeing the scripture and how it talks
about money there's over 2 300
scriptures that involve wealth and money
which is shocking to me what do they say
well for example Proverbs 22 7 says the
borrower is slave to the lender the rich
rule over the poor and so it's one of
the reasons that I'm just like yeah the
borrower's slave to lender I don't want
to be beholden to anyone financially
like I don't want to be in change
doesn't it depend on the terms
necessarily because let's say the lender
is lending at one percent then it seems
like maybe you know maybe the rules but
if if you're let's say you're you know
do you have any siblings the half sister
okay so she loans you a hundred thousand
dollars at one percent does that not
change the relationship when she sees
you going on vacation it does and buying
a car and you know but that's assuming
that uh you know but that changes the
relationship that's already there
because we're going from sibling
relationship to now she she has power
over like what I spend money on but with
the bank you don't have that like
sibling relationship to begin with it's
always it's very transactional right
exactly but even then you said like what
if it all goes down and so if it all
goes down your best position is to not
owe anyone anything
in that regard right but I also think
that if you put enough money down and
you're safe with the property you fix it
up let's just saying real estate real
estate standpoint you could always sell
it you could if it's worth much at that
point correct and so we all you know
Dave shared his story last time but
obviously it was a different time back
then but lender called all the notes
bank got sold and all of a sudden he
couldn't swing the two million dollar uh
you know notes that were owed in time
sell even selling them off fast enough
and so he got burned by that obviously
and and since then has looked at what
the Bible has to say about money
and even when it comes to investing I
mean the Bible's chock full
um Proverbs 13 11 says wealth gained
hastily will dwindle but whoever gathers
little by little will increase it and
I'm like the Bible was coming after the
crypto bros before it even existed I
mean you talk about wealth gained
hastily will dwindle money that comes in
really fast will leave just as fast
money that you slowly build up over time
ends up staying with you for a longer
period of time so there's just such
wisdom in that regardless of if you
believe in the Bible or you have a faith
background it's hard to not see the
wisdom in that Common Sense principle
and so it's one of the reasons why I own
zero crypto I just have no interest in
the anxiety of it and gaining it fast
and losing it faster I'm okay with my
401k slowly building at the rate of the
market over 20 years and you think that
that wisdom is due to like the long term
just like constantly ingraining those
philosophies of like you know you work
honest work and you just kind of save up
a little by little and you're Frugal
with your money that is more valuable
than making a bunch of money over yeah
well and I think when you work for the
money which I mean not that if you
research the right single stocks and
like you did that is work right but when
you like toil like there's like labor
involved you show it up and put in the
work it feels different than like luck I
picked the right stock at the right time
right someone who wins the lottery for
example there's a recent lottery winners
their life implodes generally and they
end up losing all that money their
family comes after them versus someone
who earned that money through a business
for example yes over time customers gave
them you know certificates of
appreciation with presidents faces on it
saying thank you for providing the
service that's what YouTube does when
you put out great content and people
watch that content when I just chose the
winning lottery ticket I know internally
I didn't deserve that
and so it changes the way you view that
money and view that wealth and
oftentimes you're tempted to go spend it
all yeah I've rarely seen lottery
winners or like I took all the money and
I just invested it in an S P 500 Index
Fund and I haven't touched it instead
it's
this changes everything the greed sets
in yeah it doesn't and we've seen that
in the crypto world there's so much
greed in that world and I'm not saying
everyone who does crypto is evil or
anything like that but we've seen a lot
of scammers and frauds and grifters
enter that space and it's it's it can be
a get rich quick kind of mentality where
they're going if I just get in the right
meme coin well three weeks from now or a
year from now that could turn into this
much and so that is just too much
anxiety and too much responsibility for
me to handle versus going I'm just going
to earn my pay every day over time and I
plan on working until I can't work
anymore because I think we were created
to work we were created to contribute
and that's a you know with the anti-work
movement that's a hard pill for a lot of
people to swallow now what I didn't say
was work for a toxic company for 30
years doing something you hate that's
what they hear in their mind when we say
working is good you know like I want you
to work in such a way that you can do
the things you want to do and find that
balance and you guys have done that
you're in the content creator space you
own your schedules and time more than
most people do
and so you're doing something you love
hopefully I mean Jack seems like he's
having a right time right jack yeah I
absolutely love it so we're here look at
us here I'm doing something I love it's
incredible that I get to just show up
and do this and help people every day
and spread the word and so yeah I mean
that all of these discussions
it get it can get esoteric and
philosophical and all these things but
I've just found my way didn't work
culture's way didn't work and so I went
in a whole other direction and followed
someone else's proven plan that was
based on biblical principles and it
worked and so that's there's no argument
it's just like that it's my story and I
think it works for anyone who wants a
piece of that it is available to them I
agree
I think you should review some of Jack
spending well I don't I don't know like
the spending per se well how do you know
what you spend if you're not doing a
budget because okay because I was born
with the I have I I don't like expensive
things I don't like expensive taste I
love I just naturally find the cheapest
things just fun are you more of an
experienced person because that could
come down yeah like stuff thousand
percent you'll go on expensive vacation
but you're unwilling to spend that same
amount on some nice clothes for example
that is exactly the case got it it's
funny Jack brought this up the other day
and it's true he is more frugal than I
am right now wow well why is that well I
mean if we're talking about like actual
dollar to dollar ratios yes I am more
frugal than Grand but that's also
because he has like 100 times more
wealth than I do the scales are
different exactly but
um yeah I would say like because you
know we booked an Airbnb here and gosh
it took me convincing to get Jack this
Airbnb it was a lot of money man dude I
told he asked me for Airbnb
recommendations I said I don't do it I
don't fall for those fees I'm not I
can't stumb make the fees but here's the
thing like how much was it two grand or
something no oh gosh now it's 12.50 you
guys should just stay to my house I
could have saved you a lot of money oh
seriously we could stay at your house
absolutely you tell us this now
625 and for me 625 is a lot of money
right and for Graham 625 yeah you know
it's uh I mean if your dog if you should
have said you should have told us now if
you will have duties you'll have to wipe
my dog's butts I don't he'll do that all
right fair point I do that for free wow
yeah that's amazing why Bailey's butt
hey next time next time you guys are in
town you can stay in our guest room it's
it's rare by the way for people to wipe
their dog's butt I have a French Bulldog
and so that she has an inverted tail
it's a whole situation as you guys get
more successful at some point I'm okay
like enjoying something you know I want
a nicer Hotel I'm not staying in a Motel
6 from on the road I I think it could be
like a financial thing as well as maybe
an age thing like I don't really have
back issues right now so for me it
doesn't really matter young again
comfiest bed or like grammar out here
the old guy is going on I didn't even
know what I did and I tweaked my back
like here's a good example I wanted to
spend the extra thirty dollars to pick
our seats at the front of the plane
no we could save the 30 and sit anywhere
that's true it just doesn't matter the
back of the plane is fine but uh you
know I I honest I don't do plane
upgrades most upgrades I I find are a
scam I'm not worth the price 30 bucks it
really choose a seat versus now if
you're gonna have a middle seat front no
like back of the plane because we were
like three rows from the back or you
could pick the front of the plane not
first class right now like what airline
are you guys
are friends he likes early boarding and
and I think that's weird because I don't
want to just sit in the plane for as
long as I would way rather sit in the uh
in the actual airport than go to the
plane because then you're standing and
waiting well he gets and single you know
he's got to you can't sit still too long
exactly oh I like to sit down because
you need to get work done I don't know
point is I think I I can't explain it
but it really just doesn't mean anything
for me to to look at price tag of a
jacket and think I like this jacket more
because I see the price tag is bigger
I'm sure you guys feel similarly but it
just it the brands any of that stuff I
really couldn't care less that makes
sense you know I think that's very
self-aware and I've got a smart spender
framework that I cover in Financial
Peace University and it's real simple
and we cover you know how how to be a
wise spender how to be a smart spender
the S is for self-awareness will this
add value to my life you're already
saying no you're cutting it off right
there this is not going to add a lot of
utility to my life it's not worth the
purchase I appreciate you calling it
self-awareness and I would love to
credit it to that but I genuinely just
think some people are born that way and
I think I was born that way like this
jacket right here I am 10 out of 10
happy to wear I'm jealous some guy sent
it to me wow do you want one we'll send
you one I thought you have custom merch
actually this would be a perfect plug
for a website down below in the
description we bought iced coffee hour
dot Club we're working on getting iced
coffee hour.com working yeah so right
now you can go to iced coffee hour.club
in the description we have merch now
available but because I'm so Frugal and
I don't want you guys to ship it to me
because that costs money so next time
you see me it's our gift but it's true
and that's what honestly I know you said
you're not a big budgeter but budgeting
has freed me to spend with
intentionality and so I don't ever see
it as restrictive of like well why do I
need to track it like I'm going to spend
less than I make I'm going to have money
left over it's fine I'm investing and
you guys again you're like the one
percent yes I find that when I budget
for the vacation and I spend that money
on the vacation or the car or the
clothing I feel good about it because I
did it with intentionality instead of
regret remorse or impulse and so I
wonder if that might be the ticket for
you I know it's counterintuitive I just
I agree I think the intention is nice
and everything but I also think like if
you look at it from uh actually like on
a sheet of paper like the value of my
time if I'm gonna go and like budget
everything and like be very like
proactive about it and intentional like
you mentioned I just don't think that it
would really change anything for me like
if you assigned a reasonable budget for
someone I'm far beneath that
so I for me spending the extra time on
something like that wouldn't really
matter and I would argue the same for
Graham yeah what's your views on
budgeting these days I don't anymore uh
because my default is always just don't
spend money it's always the default um
so when I do it's like like your bank
transaction list is very light I imagine
no it wouldn't be necessarily light but
the goal is just always don't spend
unless I have to I would say the biggest
Splurge at this point is probably
food
um
that would be it that's a luxury that's
worth it to you yeah yeah but it's
usually at the end of the day like I'll
set goals for myself I'll say I'll be
able to get sushi like doordash sushi
which is seventy dollars for like Macy
hurts my heart seventy dollars both of
us so 35 each delivered for sushi at
home if I get my whole video planned and
felt and I'll make that goal you dangle
it yeah I dangle it and then once I do
that you're driven I'm like okay now I
deserve that so but I don't just if I
don't finish it I don't deserve it
that's interesting Hospital rewards I
think which you're you're doing it right
and I'm I'm the same way like I don't
feel like I should get something until
I've kind of earned it so I've switched
I deserve it or three words that have
caused a lot of people to become broke
obviously not in this context but this
term like I deserve it I work so hard
I'm just gonna doordash because I worked
a long day at work I'm gonna spend 70
bucks but I've switched I deserve it to
I've earned it and it feels different in
that way
because deserve comes up from a place of
entitlement but I think earning it is
different so when we were paying off our
house I said I'm driving an 09 Civic the
Bumper's hanging off this thing Dave's
making fun of me I paid six grand for it
from an old team member here and I said
I'm not upgrading that car until we pay
off the mortgage and it was so freeing
to do that because I felt like I had
earned it so we paid off the mortgage I
saved up I paid cash for the Tesla and
so you made the video was it you had a
Tesla for how many how much a month 78
so I'm still planning on doing the video
how I got a Tesla for zero dollars a
month that's that's that's funny and
that's the kind of counter cultural
stuff where it's just like it's weird in
today's world to not have a car payment
it's weird to not use a credit card and
30 years ago it was totally weird to use
debt for everything we do and do buy now
pay later on a freaking pizza but now we
just live in this culture where it
becomes normal it's marketed to us and
so we just start going well now you're
the weird one for not doing that you
know yeah but I think there's such value
in switching those words from I deserved
it to I've earned it and doing it with
cash because then there's no there's no
rear view mirror going I gotta pay for
that thing I did four months ago it's so
freeing to just be done with that
transaction in that moment I actually
completely agree I've virtually removed
the word deserve from my vocabulary at
this point and I've switched it to earn
because I think not only like obviously
there are certain things in life that
are deserved like people deserve certain
like obviously things but I think the
just the mentality alone kind of similar
to what you were preaching earlier where
like it's more so about Shifting the
underlying psychology the than the
actual like uh then the net change you
know what I mean you know what's funny
similarly Dave Dave's line anytime
someone calls into the shows better than
I deserve but you guys know what that's
about it okay so this is interesting a
lot of people don't understand the
context behind it because it's not
always explained
when he says better than I deserve it is
a statement of Grace like he's actually
referring to his faith not like better
than I deserve because I'm a
multi-millionaire he's saying like like
biblically speaking like I deserved yes
better than I deserve he's saying
biblically speaking he deserved hell he
deserved the worst because of his sin
nature and instead he has the grace of
Jesus right and so that's what he's
referring to when he says that and it's
an interesting point when it comes to
money because normally we don't weave
that part into it but like when we talk
about doing a budget we put giving first
we say 10 giving at the top of your
budget if you go to a local church your
local church is a great spot for that
but it changed the way I handle money
personally because I realize like oh if
I'm a steward of what I what I've been
given right we'd all say like I'm so
blessed right like you you've said that
like I'm just really blessed man to me
what that means is I didn't deserve this
I now have this pile of money that you
know God has given me to manage I want
to be a good manager of it and that
changes the way I make decisions I'm
like should I spend frivolously over
here or should I invest wisely and
there's the parable of the talents in
the Bible where the guy went hey I'm
going to give you some I'm going to give
you some and he rewarded the one who
turned it into more money
versus the one who just you know buried
it in the dirt in the tin can in the
backyard
so there's so many interesting
principles biblically speaking that have
changed the way that I just view Money
personally coming from my background but
it's really interesting even to study it
from a financial perspective to go like
if Graham is a steward of what he's been
given right this amazing net worth this
real estate portfolio this platform that
you've been given it just changes the
way you view it and I think it makes you
less selfish because you start thinking
about things that are deeper yeah it's
not all about views and clicks it's
about influence and impact and Legacy
and generational change and so when
people do other debt-free scream on the
show they say I've changed my family
tree like I had a generational curse
from my parents and their parents and
there was abuse and there was trauma
there was addiction and there was debt
and I'm the first one in my family who's
going to turn that all around and that
brings tears to my eyes every time we
get to do those screams because it
reminds me of the real reason because we
love talking about money we're all a
bunch of nerds talking about money but
when you have that level of depth behind
it of kind of this eternal mindset it
just changes the way I I make decisions
personally now when I see like I'm a
steward of this versus like this is
George's money and he deserves it so
he's going to do what he wants with it
no one tells George what to do it just
makes me more open-handed with money and
that's part of the financial piece that
I think you feel when you walk into this
place and see all of us I'm just curious
you mentioned sinning nature what does
that mean well I mean the we talk about
you know the fall of Man like biblically
speaking Adam and Eve they sinned that's
called the fall of Man and so you know
we say that God sent Jesus to Earth to
save us from our sins and it was a
personal thing it was for Jack it was
for Graham and so that's what we say
when we say sinful nature and it's
partially why I always I'm like I'm not
going to be the guy who wins because I
have a sinful nature that's selfish that
wants what's best for George that wants
everybody have a sinful nature everyone
every human regardless of your faith
background or where you come from like
we're all Sinners right that's why we
get frustrated seeing the heartbreaking
news
of all that's broken in the world and
we're frustrated by it and while there's
a lot of good things and good news out
there it's hard to ignore all of the bad
and so it it changed the way I viewed it
when I'm like we're all Sinners but we
have a god with Grace who sent his son
to come die for us
so that we could have eternal salvation
and so I don't see it as like a I
avoided hell like that's great and I
know like I can't take my wealth with me
and so I view it differently like what
am I doing this all for let's say I have
a hundred million dollars when I die
what's it all for
well Proverbs says a good man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
great that gives me an awesome goal the
Bible also says take care of the poor
and the widows and the orphans so one a
goal for my wife and I is to pay for
someone's adoption or pay for them to
get an IVF treatment so that they can
adopt and so there's a lot it just
changes your mindset and your goals when
it comes to money
when you view it through the lens of
generosity and Legacy and faith and baby
step seven which we didn't cover which
is build wealth and give
and so that give part is important
because you guys have heard Dave say
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else and he
has amazing stories of outrageous
generosity and spontaneous generosity
and it's the stuff on Tick Tock that
makes us cry right when we watch these
videos of someone giving a stranger or a
waitress a thousand dollars and they're
in tears there's something just
beautiful about giving back it's the
reason Mr Beast is so successful we're
all inspired by the way he has taken
generosity and created amazing content
out of it and so I think it's just
important for anyone watching to have a
deeper why like making money is great
being wise with money is awesome but
without the why behind it you just get
to a point where you hit a wall and
you're like what is this all for me
there's got to be more than just like
the next spread the next thing the next
stock and so that's partially why it's
given me such peace is I'm not messing
with all that stuff I'm just going
what's right for my family what can I do
for my community what can I do to leave
an impact and leave a legacy
um because on my on my gravestone it's
not going to be like George Campbell net
worth 24 4 million dollars you know like
yeah mine though that Graham for sure is
going to have that like I want it to be
about more than that and so that's just
changed the way I handle money and it's
maybe it's freed me from going like well
I really need to get to this net worth
it's instead it's like hey what's our
goal for the next one year when it comes
to generosity and spending because
there's only three things you can do
with money give it save it and spend it
that's it I mean on the simplest terms
and so me and my wife we just set goals
in all those areas how do we want to
give this year
what are the spending goals we have this
year that might be vacations and
upgrading the car or whatever and
they're saving how do we want to invest
for the future and that has freed me to
just not get so in my head about what
could be and what's the next thing and
what is this person doing instead you
just run your own race and there's such
beauty to not caring about what other
people think and shutting down the
comparison mode to where you go like
what's that guy doing and how's that
Creator doing it has just freed me
emotionally because I'm a high anxiety
person naturally
so my goal is just to reduce all of the
anxiety I can in my life and part of
that is living with no debt part of that
is giving generously because I find that
it's hard to have a lot of anxiety when
you are giving and so those are all
components that create this weird puzzle
that is Ramsey Solutions what would you
say are some of the biggest contributors
to that philosophy that you've adopted
and grew over time
the biggest contributors to that
philosophy obviously it takes someone
speaking into your life and taking new
information I mean so many people have
been inspired by Graham and what he's
done I was super inspired by Dave Ramsey
of course as one of the goats in this
space of not only just giving us
financial information but also giving us
hope and motivation like we
underestimate how entertaining Dave is
and how motivating he is and how hopeful
he is what's your recommendation for the
best bank
uh as far as online high-yield savings
accounts I found Ally and Marcus to have
the best interface customer service I
haven't been marketed a lot of debt
products from them and so I have no
affiliation with them but I just found
them to be the ones that I'm comfortable
recommending to people it's interesting
allies the number one Auto lender wow
yeah interesting they have the the most
auto loans out there wild yeah yeah but
they also have such a great interface
and uh high-yield savings account well I
heard this Jack you were going to take
out
Caleb was telling you to take out a car
loan even though you don't need to in
order to increase your credit score so
that you have better access to debt yeah
right I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do the
the auto loan thing just because it's
just another headache at this point yeah
and my credit score is already fine it's
like 760. oh you're fine um he's all
right but the kid's all right that
that's it but it is a funny like you
have to admit it's kind of an insane
game that it is yeah like especially if
you already have like such a long track
record of like making credit card
payments and like I have a mortgage and
everything that it would be weird just
like oh take out even more debt even
when it you don't really need to play
the game I feel like of course yeah but
see I realize like the game is kind of
like a rat in the Maze and you get to
the cheese which is the 850 credit score
and you realize I'm a rat in a mace like
I'm still not truly free you're beholden
to this system but like like this is
such a one percent example but if you
want to get an exotic car loan they want
you to have Grim uh that is about five
minutes left here today and this is what
you want the Exotic Car Loan we have
five minutes people are curious if they
want to get a loan to buy a Ferrari or
Lamborghini let's say you have a 500 000
a year income it's going to be very
difficult to get a loan on that because
they want to see you have experience
handling other types of exotic car loans
so they want you to get like a Nissan
GTR or like a sub hundred thousand
dollar car loan to be able to show that
you're responsible
one hundred thousand here's what you're
saying you're like this is stupid is
what I'm hearing at the end of the day
like it's insane if you make 500 000
you're saying if at one point you want
that car you have to like get your foot
in the door to get a loan like that to
work your way up it's I think it's
stupid but I also think if that's your
goal at some point is to be able to
leverage your money and do that then you
have to that's the thing is there's just
such a it's a it's a different goal
thing like Dave Ramsey's not like how
can I leverage debt to get the next car
he's like like if you want to buy that
Lamborghini like the shortest path is
Dave's way which is I have cash I
purchase car end of discussion and so
it's just an easier way to live it's a
more free way to live Dave has very nice
cars and toys and he's got his hobbies
that he really enjoys and I just found
like that's the path that's best for me
and I I think it works for everyone it
may not be the path people choose but
it's such a great
common denominator to go like no matter
where you came from your background how
smart you are what degree you have being
debt free and having money in the bank
always works investing for the future
with and things with a great track
record that aren't as volatile like
index funds and mutual funds and real
estate you're going to be okay
regardless of if you had an inheritance
or if your family if you got the right
degree and so that's just freeing to me
because it goes like anyone can do it
and if I can do it anyone for sure can
do it because I'm not special like I
don't I'm not as smart as you guys I'm
not Savant you are yeah I would
completely disappoint I appreciate that
yeah but it's it's a fun discussion and
I know like we we're all friends and so
it's fun to have these discussions
knowing like none of us are here to like
I'm Gonna Change Graham's mind and he's
going to become debt Freedom it's fine
you're going to be okay I'm talking to
everyone else out there who thinks
they're the next gram who's going to get
themselves into a really big pickle
because they thought debt was going to
be their friend and it turns out it
screwed them over we only have like a
minute left but do you think it would be
more responsible for us to be anti-debt
I don't think it's a responsibility
issue I think you're both responsible
upstanding gentleman and you'll have a
you'll have a great life and a great
retirement like I'm truly not worried
about you guys right but impact do I
think you have a Freer life do I think
you'll have a more peaceful life yes
and like Dave mentioned I've never met
people who paid off all their debt and
they're like man I really miss having
those payments like I could have had if
I had leveraged it I could have had this
much there is such freedom and just
being content and being okay with where
you're at and not needing more and so I
find that it's not a responsibility
issue it's just a freedom issue final
question what's your biggest insecurity
oh my gosh biggest insecurity uh I mean
obviously you're like my looks like
that's an obvious thing when you're on
camera every day your console against
all right is there hair out of place
like you know I'm very pale get a
haircut every other week we spoke about
right we did every two weeks I get my
hair cut uh so I mean obviously like
looks are as far as insecurities you
know I've never been the smartest in the
room or the most well spoken and so
there's always insecurities when you're
around amazing communicators like we
have here at Ramsey so I always kind of
feel like the the dumbest guy in the
room so what I do to overcome that is I
just prepare more than them I Google
more than them I do more research I have
to work harder at it
but I'm not a super insecure person I'm
definitely an overthinker but uh in
security I wouldn't say is is my uh
token do you have any insecurities uh
maybe now I do I was like I don't think
I'm very insecure and then you're like
I'm not the best you know or the the
most well spoken but again like well
he's better more better more overcoming
security I think self-awareness helps
overcome that self-awareness will help
you overcome insecurity self-what
self-awareness just having the
self-awareness to go like I'm not the
smartest guy so what can I do about it
yeah I'm gonna go research and get
prepared and so that's freed me in a lot
of ways but honestly I I mean I had more
confidence than I did 10 years ago you
know and I think growth maturity
marriage will do that that's a fun fact
I mean marriage brings out all the flaws
in a person and helps make you better
and so there for insecurities you can
ask my wife she'll she'll be way more
honest she'll list them off come on in
Whitney no she she was not standing
outside the door thank you I think we're
are we done we're good on time we're
good cool cool thank you George this was
absolutely incredible shout out out to
everybody in the crew over here thank
you all very much guys thank you guys
for coming by it's I I truly like it is
such an honor to be on the ice coffee
hour and to be hanging out with you guys
you're doing incredible work helping so
many people educating people and helping
them avoid some of the awful traps that
are out there it is an honor to have you
on really appreciate it hey cheers
cheers to free iced coffee from Ramsay
here we go someone thanks guys for
watching